Josh: Morning.
Josh: How are you this morning?
Josh: I don't know if you're a
Josh: here to observe or not, but
Josh: I can't hear any audio on your end.
Josh: Can you hear me? Okay.
Interviewer: Hello!
Josh: Hello there!
Interviewer: Sorry about the josh. I don't know why my zoom is acting up to do.
Josh: Oh, dear. So I had to login from some other device. At least, I'm great. How about yourself?
Interviewer: I'm doing good, doing good other than the
Josh: the Zoom King happens to the best of us. Unfortunately.
Interviewer: Yeah. So okay, before we get started, have you been able to install both the apps?
Josh: I was able to install money manager.
Josh: But no scribe kept coming up with an error whenever I tried to open the dot A. PK. Saying.
Josh: I didn't have access to the Internet. So I'm not sure what's going on with that one.
Josh: Okay, can we try to install that again? Maybe troubleshoot there, let me go into my Google drive. Can you see my phone screen?
Interviewer: Yeah, okay, okay.
Josh: they want. They want another
Josh: is my speech rate too fast?
Interviewer: A bit. Yeah, okay.
are we? All right?
Josh: Awesome. Okay, excellent. Excellent.
Interviewer: Is that better? Thank you.
Josh: Better. Sure. Let me go ahead. I uploaded it to Google drive, because I don't currently use dropbox. Let me
Josh: pocket cap, close. All adventure money manager.
Josh: And that's our tribe
Josh: options, close money.
Josh: Whatever cartload. Okay, my books media folder.
Josh: These are
Josh: computer documents. Download more posing video
Josh: questions or no. This notice. 5. Do, I believe, right?
Josh: Open package installer, open it with package installer oops, unable to access document, reason, connection, error. Please make sure you haven't had to connection to the Internet and try again.
Josh: And that's the error I got last time.
Josh: But I'm pretty sure I'm connected to the Internet. If you can see my phone screen.
Interviewer: Yep,
Interviewer: let's see.
Interviewer: And you're saying you don't have
Interviewer: dropbox. But can you open the link on Google chrome?
Josh: Yeah, that's what I did.
Interviewer: Yeah, II think I think what happens is because this app is
Interviewer: built. not with Google type. So we will drive flag set.
Interviewer: Let me
Josh: do you have the Fpk downloaded in your files?
Josh: I've got it downloaded to Google Drive. Yes. And when I tried to open it directly from Google Chrome, it said, can't open file. But that also happened with
Interviewer: the money manager app as well. I had to. Oh, so that that you can't download it from Dropbox.
Josh: not directly using Google Chrome.
Josh:  I could try
Josh: going to the play store and installing the dropbox app and see if
Josh: that might make any difference. I didn't do that because I don't normally use dropbox.
Interviewer: I see. I see? Yeah, I'll also had Google drive link. But
Interviewer: it was
Interviewer: creating problems for testers. So I change it to dropbox.
Interviewer:  yeah, they strive drop books. Not not there, just through chrome
Josh: money manager. Page page 2 or 3,
Josh: page one, page 2, and 3 of them grow, cannot grow
Josh: navigate. Search
Josh: sunny. There's no shadows. Oh, but
Josh: sign in, switch. Our close tab. More options, annotation button windows share audio annotation more options. Switch our close, tab new tab, tab
Josh: little dude celebrating these money. Search for Star Voice. Search
Josh: download Facebook messenger. We're fine. They all know these, no search. When your camera using Google bands start voice search. We're talking with Ms edit, box
Josh: system speakers, choose, input, method. Okay. David.
Josh: and and okay, okay, go on
Josh: 0 progress part, keyboard package of accessibility powered by people with disabilities. Webu, 80. Go ahead and log into my dashboard. My apologies about this.
Interviewer: No, it's all right. We've had this problem with the
Josh: spoken language. speechwrite
Josh: join world, famous classic
Josh: extended collapse products. But once you're single.
Josh: yeah, I may go ahead and stop that problem. 13 or 13 advanced drive. advanced money manager. and then zoom
Josh: zoom got you, Josh Josh zoom leave recording chat, but for reaction, stop, share, show captions up, stop share
Josh: wi-fi or something. There we go.
Josh: 1, 2, currently. And that's not tribe
Josh: advanced options drop chrome, 12 chrome zoom, picture and picture collapse. Here's a stable collapse. Community collapse resource collapse expanded about our testers become a tester fable path, collapse resources, login.
Josh: 0% progress mark, edx, email log in as a potential usage password for one. Continue. But keyboard sign, we don't. 0 Webu. 80
Josh: tabletop welcome. You are logged in orange change account. Password password is hidden
Josh: up.
Josh: Password is less of credentials. You say password for password, lesser credentials is close dashboard.
Josh: spoken like with 5, 3 audio talking accessibility, character, words, dashboard, quick ass, table path, feedback surveys, request web schedule, request, user interview, row to request time track tracking your expenses with money, Webview. 5% tracking your expenses with money manager, copy, one table, Webview. Not a table in progress. Request 52% tracking your expenses with money manager call tracking your exertion details, cutting 2
Josh: in homestead
Josh: details, type description with money manager. You can description, join meeting. discretion, details confirmed audience, time for environment. It's not 1B min for the study. We need to install to ask for dropbox.
Josh: first, the money manager, app. Second, the note 26. Nova Scot drop drop offs 66.
Josh: I'll go ahead and start my screen share again, so you can see what I'm seeing.
Josh: 13 or 13 events zoom.
Josh: zoom, share, button 609. Share button, 609. Zoom. Microsoft microbox photo document
Josh: start recording or passing pass. Start system, white wi-fi zoom 13 or 13. It's not share. Button window annotation, board clock. bard, mobile annotation. Share you annotation, barn o'clock, money, man, a pocket close, all advanced zoom.
Josh: and that's not cool.
Josh: Dropbox
Josh: to close.
Josh: Get a better view with our mobile notice. Get a better view close Nova Scotia. Flop offs Nova scribe job captions.
Josh: You not
Josh: close exiles. Can't carnivate preview.
Josh: Yeah. Those classic calendar. So I hit download
Interviewer: download file again.
Josh: Oh, button connection. Dropbox, stop, start, voice, search, switch our click more options download file again.
Josh: Oh, and it's giving me a download file again, because I've already downloaded at once. Do you want to download?
Interviewer: So you have it in your files
Josh: somewhere? I'm not. Normally, I don't. Usually
Josh: anything. I access on my phone is usually over the Internet. Cancel download again.
Josh: Downloading. Oh, but file download option available on your top of the screen.
Interviewer: And it's open.
Josh: Yeah.
Interviewer: Okay? Then you have to go to your settings to
Interviewer:  change. Change!
Interviewer: Oh.
Josh: sound the settings! I'll just let you know. Utilities folder one notification.
Josh: Come on, and settings place up settings
Josh: display.
Josh: Oh, sweet loser, security, location, location, locate security and privacy.
Josh: security and privacy can't pick up button. Not a question.
Interviewer: And there should be something called install apps from epiphones
Interviewer: or so, or like, allow unknown sources.
Josh: accounts, fine, mobile security. Good. 5 or 17.
Josh: Would that be under app security?
Josh: No, that is sound. Some pass used by secure folder. 1117 secured. Wi-fi. 12, 7. Try to share share files, sound something, store.
Josh: It's not one. No house, 15 or 17
Josh: install one. No.
Josh: Chrome. 68.3 3 gmail my files, and that's my files.
Interviewer: Hopefully, this will work. Let's go back to oh, yeah, the dialers folder and then
Josh: try opening. Just now. No described more options, but no described. Ap. 5. No described 1 5.5
Josh: more option.
Josh: no more options. Button kind of like no scrap job if you can't, can't open file.
Interviewer: No, it's just oh, it's still kind of
Josh: more an option. No, it's fine. Can't open files.
Josh: I do have the money manager app. If that
Interviewer: a
Josh: I was able to get that installed. It's for some reason.
Josh:  the Node Manager, or whatever that app is, it really does not seem to care for that app
Interviewer: fixes. Okay.
Interviewer: yeah, I think it's it's not possible to install it. It's alright. We'll go ahead with the money manager.
Josh: That app been problematic for other testers, too.
Josh: Money measure.
Interviewer: Yeah, it has been
Interviewer: okay, but not a pager
configured somehow.
Josh: Okay.
Interviewer: Alright. So let me introduce myself.
Although I've we've met before.
Interviewer: I'm >
Interviewer: and today, I'd like to analyze the accessibility of the open source android application called money manager, and with money manager you can keep track of your expenses, and this app has features that let you add transactions and income.
Interviewer: You can create budget plans to keep track of your spending. The app also provides analysis of your spending habit. Now.
Interviewer: In the first phase I will ask you to explore and use the app. The money manager app without any instructions for me. So it's like you install them new app. You will know what it does, and you just want to explore and use the features.
Interviewer: And during this phase please think aloud. It is very essential for our research that you speak in mind continuously about what you're doing and experiencing because we want to analyze the transcript.
Josh: Okay?
Interviewer: And in this phase, if you encounter any obstacles or blockers, take some time to explore a solution, you can abandon that task and find it impossible.
Interviewer: Okay. after you think you explored the app and its functionalities substantially, or time starts finding out.
I'll ask you to conduct certain tasks.
Josh: Okay.
Interviewer: at the end of your interview I will ask you to revise the accessibility and usability issues you encountered. So at least some of the things that you already encountered.
Interviewer: Do you have any questions regarding all that? No. okay, great. So, and during the session, if you need any break or want to stop, please let me know.
Interviewer: Alright. If you're ready, let's start. Today's session.
Interviewer: So you already have manual app open so you can explore it. freestyle.
Josh: Okay, so open that. Okay?
Josh: It looks like the first thing he at the top is a navigation drawer. So just to see what's in there, I'm going to go ahead and double tap on it. Money manager, manage your budget tracker expenses and control plans.
Josh: check month expenses, budget categories.
Josh: budget analysis, monthly expenses, analysis budget plans, annotation, button windows, zoom, budget plan, monthly budget analysis, budget check money manager check month expenses.
Josh: budget categories.
Josh: checked month's expenses. So I see right now, we're listing month's expenses. So
Josh: chat months, expenses, more options, but double tap to get out of there. Month expenses, open allocation for months, more options. But category name.
Josh: You're expensive this month.
Josh: Total expenses add expense, button, button, annotation, button windows. You add expense, total category, more options, button category. Name
Josh: more options, month expenses, open navigation for. But
Josh: so I've seen the options here. So I'm going to open up that navigation budget check month expense budget categories.
Josh: But analysis
Josh: budget categories more options. But I want to see what's in here. Public window. You'll want it in list and comment. Add in comment, so I want to go under. Add income.
Josh: I do what I don't come button out of my amount at a box
Josh: system states. Choose, include method, multilingual tagging or showing on the keyboard. This is all pretense. This is not real. 3,
2,
Josh: 2, 8,
Josh: home window navigation bar, 5, 8.
Josh: State.
Josh: aye.
Josh: 5, 8, 8, 6, 6. The one disadvantage to sharing the screen is unfortunately the zoom
Josh: share. Notification blocks the 0.
Josh: So see the 0. But that's okay. I wish I had this as much money. But
Josh: money manager, keyboard money manager, open navigation work but once expenses, more options, but
Josh: category. Name your expense of this month. Total expenses
Josh: have expense, 1. One.
Josh: That new transaction product category. Drop down, list protected. Your honor hasn't kept and thank you. And the folks
Josh: protected. Click on down, drop down list.
Josh: enter info edit box characters enter 0 with him.
Josh: Enter info at a box. Character. Enter info edit. Box. This is a little strange character. Enter info, transact 2,020 transaction date
Josh: 2,023,
Josh: Friday, September fifteenth previous month, but next month. But the first September 2,000 2,000 transaction enter info character. Enter info, edit box protected, icon down, drop product category.
Josh: a new transaction.
Josh: but protected icon down, drop down list.
Josh: enter info edit box.
Josh: So it says, enter info. But I'm not sure what info it's looking for. If it's looking for a category name.
Josh: or what this is cause, then there's another
Josh: edit box with the same name enter info.
Josh: So I'm not sure what's going on there. What I may try doing, though money manager at expense, button, but total extensive. Your extensive category going back into an option. But category. Name
Josh: one option month's expenses, open navigation drawer, navigation drawer.
Josh: money, money manager, check month extent, budget categories.
Josh: categories, and add a category or 2.
Josh: Have our name
Josh: more options, but budget category more options.
Josh: Pop up window your wallet in list, add account settings, annotation, button automatic settings. Add and com your wallet.
Josh: add a comment.
Josh: Money manager, more options, category. Name
Josh: budget
Josh: protected like on it, but
Josh: annotation button to check it. Click on it. Button budget, category info category. Name characters enter 0 or 50 amount of money you can spend in this category. Edit box characters enter 0 or 50
Josh: budget right? The maximum amount of money you can spend in this category. Edit box
Josh: system states, choose and put it to
Josh: 2, one.
Josh: 4, 4, 6, 3,
Josh: 3,
Josh: 6, 6,
Josh: anything, 2,400 great, clear test, right? The maximum amount of money you can spend in this category. Annotation, button windows, clear, anything, check characters enter 0 category. Name, edit box.
Josh: Yeah, yeah.
Josh: 2,001 character editing budget category info.
Josh: It's not share button. Share my annotation. Item, button window, right? And that's another item.
Josh: Keyboard hit money manager, open navigations, more budget, more options. But category name.
Josh: But it's fun in West
Josh: budget category, more options, budget category
Josh: money manager months expenses.
Josh: check month expenses.
Josh: We're launching category more expensive this month.
Josh: 0 sorry $0, 2,000 total expenses, expense button. But
Josh: on a new transaction product category
Josh: protected icon down, drop down this.
Josh: enter info edit box, protected. Click on down pop-up, window fun investment.
Josh: annotation. Button up front in this window, Hobb.
Josh: add new transaction protected icon down. Drop down this info edit box.
Josh: So even though we've selected a category. this enter info box hasn't changed its labels. So I'm not sure if this is maybe
Josh: where you enter what it is you purchased
Josh: system space choosing. Put method, multilingual y.
Josh: Teeth.
Josh: GWWW. I.
Josh: Yes, that's what's going on.
Josh: And Friendsville at the Fox
Josh: Dollar sign showing number key one.
Josh: okay.
3,
Josh: 2,
Josh: great.
Josh: 2, 2,
Josh: 6 more. 80'clock characters in editing 2 edit dollar sign clear text. But transaction date 2,023 from September fifteenth.
Josh: We'll say that was today, cause
Josh: I've done some previous work with this happen the month for you gets a bit
Josh: challenging to navigate through
Josh: that new transaction category
Josh: protected icon down drop Twixmark character editing dollar. Tech transaction. 2,000 fine. Thanks. September
Josh: free. Next month, the first of September, 2,023.
Josh: Don't
Josh: the first of September, 2,023. People working
Josh: the second of September, 2,000 next month, previous month, joining September 2,023. Trans. Cleartech, 2
Josh: character gender twix more protected product admission.
Josh: It's not share share annotation. But the 20 third of September, 2,000
Josh: money manager
Josh: month's expenses.
Josh: We're not just fun
Josh: category. You're extensible.
Josh: List 0 slider, $2, 2,000 total expenses out of place, adding cents button. But
Josh: so that was fairly accessible.
Josh: Total expenses, $2 0% fun. Your expenses, category name
Josh: more options, less expenses.
Josh: Yeah.
Josh: yes, yes.
Josh: Stacey can't stifle
Josh: 5, 5,
Josh: editing PS. 5. Clip. Character. Enter info edit box.
Josh: dollar sign showing number keyboard.
Josh: 3,
Josh: 5, 5, 6, 6, 6,
Josh: bye, bye.
Josh: Transaction date, 2,000 Friday
Josh: money manager, keyboard.
Josh: Okay? Now, I'm gonna go under budget analysis, money manager, check budget categories. Budget analysis
Josh: come on. Expenses. Analysis. something else. What? Analysis?
Josh: 567. Article.
Josh: Another kind of version. fun.
Josh: fun, 0 slash 0 for more information.
Josh: listener, annotation button windows. You listen
Josh: 560 talking.
Josh: So it looks like, maybe for the analysis you have to pay for the premium version. I try to take more options. But now let's open navigation drawer. But
Josh: do you want to visit the website?
Josh: Oh, the the website to to purchase the app?
Interviewer: No, it's not purchasing the app. It's just for more details. But for our tests. Can you try going into that?
Interviewer: Our website?
Josh: Yeah, I can try
Josh: check. Click, budget, cap, check.
Josh: chat, budget analysis, morneau. We have you bye, bye, for trial. Fine
Josh: fun, 0 slash 0 for more information.
Josh: Who's there?
Josh: Annotation? Button windows. You may have to stop to share briefly, because
Josh: the share bars blocking the
Josh: the button. Yeah. URL,
Josh: it's not fair. But
Interviewer: is it?
Josh: Cheryl? Yeah, annotation. But this is now
Josh: at least, according to talkback, it is. I'm not seeing a
Josh: I'm not seeing a a way to click on a web. Yeah. URL Link.
Interviewer: for more information. Can can you click on the text visitor website?
Josh: It says, visit hour. But that's it.
Josh: Double tapping. Nothing's happening.
Interviewer: Oh, okay, in just saying, visit hour. Oh, okay, it's not even the same website.
Interviewer: Okay, yeah, we don't have to look
Josh: okay.
Josh: Open
Josh: money manager, manage your budget tracker expenses and controller plan month expenses, budget category check budget, monthly expenses, analysis.
Josh: maybe monthly analysis will let me visit their website windows. Webview window money manager windows. Web isn't accessible at all.
Josh: Talkback skipping right over it. Let me try
Josh: toggling talkback on and off, just to see
Josh: if this could be
Josh: a screen reader errors. Not that long.
Josh: or what the problem is. We're not trans annotation. But we have you window money, manager, money manager.
Josh: more notion. We have you communication button Webu window money manager.
Josh: So this web view talk back. It's not. does not seem to be able to interact with it.
Interviewer: I flick to the left. There's more options. Flick to the right
Josh: web. View, it says, but it won't let me interact with it. Flick to the right again. Now we're into the zoom contents.
Interviewer: Yeah, it is inaccessible, I guess.
Josh: See what's in there.
Josh: Money manager. More options. But Webu annotation, but share audio annotation web view win more options. But monthly except more options, Webview.
Josh: More options out of window. You don't want to add in contact settings.
Josh: money manager, more options. But we have you
Josh: patient button, web view window money manager.
Josh: and apparently either settings doesn't work or it's inaccessible, because I'm still presented with the same
Josh: window here. We're not just monthly expenses. But navigations want me to try going back to monthly expenses.
Josh: month's expenses, money manager, months, expensive
Josh: checked month's expenses more, not category. Name more expense, category more lunches.
Josh: Window. You're on conference settings.
Josh: money manager, more options, but category more expensive fun. Yeah, $23567 tapped on the settings. Option.
Josh: Nothing happened. So either that panel is inaccessible or it's A, dead. a, dead option. Missing contents.
Josh:  fun, your expenses this category name more options but month expenses, open navigation.
Josh: 1, 6 more options, but
Josh: month's expense, more option, one month expenses more option, category, more expensive fund, 2,500 total expenses add expense fund. But new transaction. Hold on category
Josh: block, youngest fun.
Josh: and for info at a box
Josh: system states multilingual hiding for showing English us.
Josh: Thank you.
Great!
Josh: That's nice. See? You see?
Josh: Yeah, yeah. Yeah. Or it it it.
Josh: Okay, huh? Character intercepts of 10. And for info at a box
Josh: dollar sign showing up 3, 3
sizes.
Josh: 3, 6,
Josh: yes.
Josh: previous month, next month, September fourteenth, 2,023, selected
Josh: today the sixteenth, the seventeenth, the eighteenth, the nineteenth, of the twentieth, twenty-fifth, the 24, the 2026, the 20B s between the 29, the thirtieth September transaction, but
Josh: transaction budget category equals one production, equals single quote copy price equals 3 6 0 Monday equals. Thursday, September fourteenth, 95 and 19B s central date time, 2,023 money manager, money manager, open navigation, sure, but keep working
Josh: most expensive more options. But category name.
Josh: you're extensible this month. Fun. Thanks. 25%, Slider. $603, $2,436,
Josh: 25%. I do think that is
Josh: what was that?
Interviewer: What do you think? That was the the numbers.
Josh: the amount of money I've spent so far, the the Slider is obviously 25% of my budget. My total budget.
Josh: $603, $2,436.
Josh: Total expenses. Total, 625 category more options, month expenses.
Josh: Just for fun. I want to go back to that budget analysis
Josh: screen and see if anything changes.
Josh: Chat, budget analysis, more options. We have you
Josh: Hi, talking titled your expenses for category. It's not with one points. I think that's one of our trial version
Josh: fun.
Interviewer: I think it was a monthly expenses. Analysis that was
Interviewer: inaccessible.
Josh: Yeah. but there was a an interesting thing under the the regular and out the budget analysis where the website wasn't showing. And I was just curious to see if
Josh: anything there a change.
Josh: annotation.
Josh: money manager, months expense budget categories, month's expensive budget, monthly expenses, monthly expenses, announcer more options.
Josh: and nothing's changed there. That's still inaccessible.
Josh: More options, monthly expenses, open applications, war but matter money manager next month's expected budget. Kind of budget analysis
Josh: check month monthly except budget plans.
Josh: See what's under budget plan budget plans.
Josh: annotation sharing yo annotation budget plans, window money manager.
Josh: check, monthly expense, analysis, budget plans. chat, budget, class more options. Your body contains enough money for this plan.
Josh: Your body contains enough money for this plan. The deadline of this plan has passed.
Josh: The deadline of this plan has passed, unable but protected click on it.
Josh: We have an unlabeled button button window protected. Click on it. Button
Josh: plan, info, land, title, edit. Box characters enter 0 with land plan info.
Josh: It's not share but share on the annotation. The thirtieth of September, 2,023, between ninth September, September the 20 ninth September 2,000, Friday, September 20 ninth, 2,023, the thirtieth
Josh: bye bye bye. Okay, sure. Button windows. Add one
Josh: money manager budget plans more options. Your wallet contains enough money for this plan. Your deadline of this plan has passed.
Josh: The deadline is protected. Iconic button, annotation, button windows protected, iconic button window. Mine manager.
Josh: the deadline of the deadline of this plan. Your body, your body contains enough, more options, budget plans.
Josh: open applications, work.
Josh: money, manager, month, monthly expense, check budget, annotation, budget, budget, month expenses, money, manager budget categories.
Josh: month's expenses.
Josh: budget category most expenses.
Josh: budget categories.
Josh: month's expense, month category name. So I've gone through. It looks like the entirety of
Josh: the actual
Josh: navigation menu, and it doesn't appear as though, the more options menu
Josh: contains anything that changes. Did. Did you want me to look at anything else?
Interviewer: I did. But thank you for navigating in place. So what do you think about it? In terms of any web app you're using?
Josh:  overall. It seemed fairly accessible.
Josh: The
Josh: the only exception to that was that monthly expense analysis screen. I'm not sure
Josh: why that didn't want to work, but
Josh: but overall. my general feeling is fairly positive.
Josh: I liked, how clearly labeled most of the elements were.
Josh: and it was relatively easy to navigate through the app using. Talk back?
Interviewer: Great. Okay.
Interviewer: Let's conduct a few s. Specific tasks.
Josh: Starting with can you add a new category?
Interviewer: Let's call it shopping.
Josh: Okay?
Josh: More expensive this month. Category. Name more options, month expenses, open navigation.
Josh: money manager, check budget, categories, budget, analysis, budget, category, protected annotation, button protected icon, window money manager, budget, category info, category, name, character category, name edit box.
Josh: Yes, yeah. Bye. Oh.
hey, hey? Hey?
Josh: Aye.
Josh: yeah. Okay.
Josh: It's nice. cheap
Josh: budget, like a maximum amount of money you can send in a category at a box window budget category info. How much money?
Interviewer: I say 500.
Josh: How much?
Interviewer: A 500? Or
Interviewer: if if you can, taxes 0, then 512.
Josh: Okay, 2 successive
Josh: 1, 1, 2, 2,
Josh: clear test amount of money
Josh: notation. But I'm calm.
Josh: Keyboard, hidden money manager, open application for budget cap. We're not category. N budget.
Josh: It is a little strange that they add categories.
Josh: Icon is labeled. Add income. Not sure
Josh: why that is. But the category's been added.
Interviewer: Yeah, can you now try to edit the fun category
Josh: name into something like category. Name status delete.
Josh: Oh, no, it doesn't appear. It says you cannot add or change the category name, apparently.
Interviewer: and you cannot edit in their text.
Josh: ma'am. I'll try typing.
Josh: Yeah. DS. Yes, CC.
Josh: Delete next.
Josh: You cannot change the category. Name money manager. You cannot change the category. Name it says.
yes.
Josh: paragraph
Josh: cancel this category. Info everything. Miss fun at a box fun.
Josh: didn't?
Interviewer: What do you think is happening?
Josh: 2,436.0 at a box budget character
Josh: as though it's not. Here we go.
Josh: Dewitt. Yeah. Dewit. See?
Josh: Delete? Yes. Do we have time delete them?
Josh: Yeah, yeah, II yeah, that's that's me.
Josh: See? See?
Josh: Next.
Josh: you cannot change the category name my manager.
Josh: Hmm.
Josh: what do we need to do?
Interviewer: What about like submitting this, as is
Josh: okay? Clear text. Alright. But that's not item fun
Josh: people working money manager, open navigation for budget. We're not a category name budget, Miss, 2,436
Josh: shopping $512. That's strange.
Josh: Can you? Can you try editing the shopping categories.
Josh: budget, category info shopping at a box category. Name shopping. You cannot change the category name money manager system status.
Josh: Okay.
Josh: Shauni. Beginning of Shauni Dando field.
Josh: Good. And we had to stay.
Josh: So we have the jeep. Do we have end? So we had aye.
Josh: 500 clear tech alright. Go back, add and call annotation share on yo annotation, adding, com money manager, miss, enlist 2,400 shop
Josh: $112. That's strange.
Josh: I wonder why it gave those messages.
Interviewer: It promised something, but it didn't come through. Yeah. Okay. let's try to add an expense for shop.
Josh: Okay.
Josh: 2,000, Miss Budget. Category, more options, budget categories, open navigation.
Josh: money manager, manager.
Josh: month's expenses, money manager, months, expense, checked months, expenses, more option category more expensive, miss. In 25603 shop $0, total expense, expense, button button.
Josh: Next, new transaction product category.
Josh: Drop down there
Josh: out the window, Miss shop Shop. A new transaction block down this shop, enter info at a box
Josh: system status, choosing, multilingual timing for showing English Us. Party. What are we buying?
Interviewer: What do you want to buy?
Josh: Alright?
Josh:  we'll say.
Josh: TRRR. IT.
Josh: Oh, yeah, yes, yes.
Josh: they're good, aren't they?
Josh: Enter info edit box
Josh: for let's say, what?
Josh: $8? 6, 2.
Josh: Where do you get your burritos?
Josh: Well, I actually prefer Jimmy Chong is, I don't know how, quite dispelled that. But
Josh: Usually they're actually not that expensive, but almost
Interviewer: see.
Josh: How about you? Do you eat them on a regular basis?
Interviewer: No, not not necessarily.
Josh: I have my serial.
Josh: Nice.
Josh: clear text. Transact 2,000 Friday, September
Josh: previous month. Let's pretend, like we're gonna do this tomorrow.
Josh: Saturday, September sixteenth, 2,023 selected the nineteenth, 26, the twenty-first, twenty-fourth, 2526, the 20 seventh, the twentieth, twenty-thirty of September transaction, but transaction, budget category equals 2 production, equals single. September sixteenth, 97, 36. Second Central Dateline, 2,023 money manager, keyboard, hidden money manager, open navigation category name. Can you tell me what your total expenses are
Josh: yeah, your expenses, your expenses this month, 25 Slider.
Josh: $603, $2,436
Josh: shop, 2 total expenses out of place, add expense, button button annotation button, addict total expenses.
Josh: add extension. One
Josh: addicia, add expense, total expenses. It says total expenses.
Interviewer: but it doesn't save the amount. Okay.
Interviewer: yeah, I can see the amount. But Tom Brigg isn't focusing on it.
Josh: Yeah.
Interviewer: okay.
Interviewer:  You didn't add a budget 20 yet, have you? Let's try adding on
Josh: open navigation reward. But
Interviewer: manage your budget, check, check check must budget categories.
Josh: budget analysis, monthly expensive analysis, budget plans.
Josh: chat budget plans, more options. You're willing to take your money windows. You protected. The deadline of this plan has passed.
Josh: It would appear to be the information for the current plan.
Josh: but I'm not sure why the deadline has passed.
Interviewer: There are no plans.
Josh: Hmm! That's strange. Then I wonder why it's saying the deadline for this plan has passed.
Josh: Alright, we can land title, edit, box
Josh: system status. Choose input, method. Multi. Yep.
Josh: to meet NM,
Josh: NNY,
Josh: yeah. DGHA. L.
Josh: Why
Josh: space one R
Josh: Romeo EE ends.
Josh: Lance budget at a box window. Plan. Info characters enter 0 50 glance budget, edit box.
Josh: dollar sign showing number keyboard
Josh: for 6, 2.
Josh: You, too.
Josh: 2, 5,
Josh: one.
Josh: 4, 4,
Josh: 2, 2, 6, 6.
Josh: Okay. Do that dollar sign
Josh: clear text, but landed on date 2,023 by September eleventh previous month, but next month but
Josh: 2,020.
Josh: Your plan I successfully money manager, keyboard money manager, open application for, but
Josh: budget plans more options, but your only contains enough money for this plan.
Josh: Your body contains enough money for this man.
Josh: The deadline. when the only plan present is for next month. I don't know why it's doing that. and there doesn't appear to be any clickable contents on those notations either.
Interviewer: and he sing it twice. Why do you think that
Josh: I'm not sure?
Interviewer: That's
Josh: I'm wondering if maybe
Josh: the deadline now
Josh: that really doesn't make sense. I wondered if maybe there were some unlabeled graphics that perhaps talkback was hanging up on. But there don't appear to be.
Interviewer: We got it. Okay. I think we're done with the tests for
Interviewer: today. As I mentioned earlier, like, I wanted to
here your list of
Interviewer: reviews like accessibility and usability issues that you found that stood up to you.
Josh: Yeah.
Josh: well, definitely, this screen, having some erroneous information on it.
Josh: is definitely a big
Josh: red flag. Given that it. It's reporting that a deadline has passed when there is no deadline. That's a serious issue.
Josh: And the fact that the monthly expense, analysis, spring was inaccessible as
Josh: most definitely another knock. But aside from that, though the app does seem relatively usable, there were some buttons, the adding
Josh: adding categories and adding expenses. Those buttons did seem to be unlabelled. So I think
Josh: talk back. Probably used optical character recognition tip. provide those labels so ideally, more clearly labeling. Those
Josh: buttons would be advisable. But
Josh: but overall. It was
Josh: quite decent.
Josh: There was that one button that was labelled Add Income, when it was only adding an expense, so that label is a bit misleading.
Josh: but those are definitely most of those, with the exception of that deadline
Josh: report.
Josh: are issues that could be quite easily overcome
of her, come home
Josh: through knowledge. through knowing what the buttons do. through also having social retail apartments ideally
Josh: potentially
Josh: relabeling those buttons ideally.
Interviewer: But after having used the app and knowing what those buttons do.
Josh: I would just know that adding income, and in that particular scenario did not mean adding more money to my walls, it just meant
Josh: submitting whatever project I was working on.
Interviewer: It was like category, I think.
Josh: Yes.
Interviewer: Got
Interviewer: okay, I think we're good for now.
Interviewer: There was the settings thing that I had you change
Interviewer: so you can go ahead and change it back with the allow
Interviewer: unknown apps. But you can do it on on your own time. You have to do it now. But yeah, thank you so much for your insights.
Interviewer: And as a disposer disclaimer, I wanted to say, like the money manager app is not.
Interviewer: does not have as many expert issues.
Interviewer: Some of them were added for our research purposes to know that the app itself isn't as as bad. But
Interviewer: yeah, but yeah, we'll analyze this data and thank you so much. Thank you. Have a wonderful day you, too! Bye, bye.